[Laughter]
[Music]
good to see you again man
good to see you thanks for having me
it's uh been like a year
it's been like a year believe it or not
you look exactly the same
and the studio looks exactly the same
you might be on another part of the
world
no one knows yeah it's just uh
my my apartment that i rent you know i i
don't like to give out a lot of
information about where i'm at and that
kind of stuff so it's
very smart a plain wool that i've got
the lights down low so it looks kind of
a
a nice gray at least i think it's nice i
think it's beautiful
it looks amazing uh first of all
congratulations on the recent ruling
was a ninth district court of appeals
is that what it was it said that what
you exposed
with the warrantless wiretapping was in
fact
illegal and there are many people that
are calling for you to be pardoned now
yeah it's so much has happened this
ruling this is actually not the first
time
the federal government has uh or the
appeals courts have struck down
uh some of the federal surveillance
programs as unlawful
um but this one is really important
because it happened uh from an appeals
court it wasn't from a single judge it
was from uh
a panel of judges um and
what they had uh ruled was that the
nsa's bulk collection
of americans phone records uh was
illegal
and this is the very first um sort of
mass surveillance program that
i and the journalists um really that the
news was broken back in 2013 so this is
a huge victory for
privacy rights uh what it means is
there was this provision of the patriot
act like remember the patriot act
remember like
a zillion years ago i do everybody was
laying out patriotic patriotic your
friend alex jones you know i think
he was worried about that it's a
terrible name the there's a real problem
with that name
because if you're against the patriot
act it's like against
babies it's like like this is the
pro-baby act but meanwhile pro-baby act
they get to look through your email
you know what i mean it's like the word
patriot is attached to that in a very
disingenuous way like calling that
the patriot act is it's really creepy
that they could do they should have like
a number like bill a1
yeah you know you know what i'm saying
so you can debate the merits of it it's
just so much propaganda
attached to that name like the patriot
act
this is one of the funny things because
it should be a warning for anybody who's
in like
you know just anywhere in the country
and they hear on the news they're
talking about like the save
puppies you know act uh there's actually
one that's
uh been they've been trying to push
through recently
which is basically outlawing meaningful
encryption from the major internet
service providers like if
facebook or google for whatever reason
got out of bed in the morning and they
actually wanted uh to protect your uh
the security of your communications
uh in a way that even they can't break
like right now
uh google and facebook they do a great
job
keeping other people from spying on your
communications
but if google wants to rifle through
your inbox right if facebook wants to go
through all your direct messages
and give that to the federal government
like you tap one button and boom they've
got all of it happens
every single day well
companies like facebook have recently
realized this is a real problem for them
uh because first off they get all these
censorship demands
um that you've seen uh where like
there's
de-platforming requests and it happens
in one country right like if the u.s
government is allowed to decide what can
and can't be said by this person on this
platform
or uh the u.s goes look we got a court
warrant
they said uh a judge said we think this
person's a criminal we want you to hand
over everything you have on this person
and they do it right facebook does this
well guess who's next right the russian
government shows up at the door the next
day the chinese government shows up the
door the next day
and if these companies don't play ball
they get shut down in that country they
can no longer
no longer operate and so the idea that a
lot of them have
uh that they've considered and this has
actually
become a bigger thing in the covid
crisis where we start talking about like
contact tracing these companies want to
know where everybody is at all the time
so they can hand this over to medical
authorities or whatever
there's this idea called end to end
encryption
which what it means is that when you
send a message
you know when billy sends a message to
bobby billy and bobby both have the keys
to unlock that message
and it could be sent through facebook it
could be sent through google it could be
posted you know on a bulletin board in
the town square
but without that key which the people
who run the bulletin board
right the the people who own the
bulletin board google facebook
they don't have that key only the phones
at the end the laptops at the end the
people
on those they're the only people who
have the key so if somebody comes to
facebook and says we want to see that
information
facebook hands over the encrypted
message
right and facebook goes well here you go
here's our copy but we can't read it
you can't either now you've got to
actually do some work
on the government side and go get that
key yourself
and then you can read it right but we
can't read it
congress is trying to stop the basically
proliferation of that basic
and encryption technology and they're
calling it like the
child online predator act or something
like that
where they say it's all about protecting
uh the
posting of like child exploitation
material and really
really horrible stuff but that's not
actually what the law is about
the law is about making it easier for
spies and law enforcement
to reach deeper and deeper into your
life with a simple warrant stamped by
any court
the funny thing is this never used to be
uh the way law enforcement worked in the
united states
i mean when you hear about a warrant
what does that mean to you what can the
cops get with a warrant
well usually i think it means that they
can come in your
house and search right the the the real
issue with
warrants in when it pertains to
encryption like when you're talking
about the child
safety act or whatever they're calling
it
anyone would say yes we have to stop
child predators
but the problem with having the ability
to use something like that to stop
child predators in my eyes i i start
thinking
well if i really wanted to look into
someone what i would do is i would send
them some malware that would put
child pornography on their computer and
then i would have
all of the motive that i need
to go and look through everything like
say if they're if they were
a political dissident if they were doing
something against the government
and you were someone who was uh acting
in bad faith and you decided okay
we want to look into this guy but we
don't have a warrant what what are the
laws
what what can we get away with it well
we have the child endangerment act
and so because of that we're allowed to
peer into anything
but we just have to have motive so we
have to well
do we have motive all you'd have to do
is and we we both know this
it's very easy to put something illegal
on someone's computer if they're not
paying attention
it's very easy to install like you could
send someone a text message that looks
like
a routing number for a package they're
going to get they click on that
and then you what is that um what the
israelis have uh pegasus
right yeah you you've read up on this
yeah so
well it's uh it's from brian fogle's new
film the dissident which is
uh about jamal khashoggi's murder and
how
the saudis used that to use they
actually
tapped into jeff bezos's phone and
that's where
all of this is the suspicion is that
that that's where all of those
uh national enquirer photos came out and
all the attacks on him
because they they had access to his
actual phone through this so someone
could easily
get into your stuff if you're not paying
attention
and then they could use you know
whatever
acts they've come up with whatever it's
the patriot act or whatever act
where they could just get into
everything you're doing look at your
whatsapp messages look at your
your facebook messages it's real sneaky
and it's it's dangerous
it's it's a dangerous precedent to set
yeah i mean there's a lot to this let me
go into some of that in a little depth
so you mentioned the nso group in their
their pegasus malware set
and this is very much a real thing like
you're a well-read guy um
this is like
this company uh the ceo's name i think
is shalev julio
um is uh run in israel it was previously
owned
uh actually by an american venture
capital firm i believe they've been uh
re-bought out
but it doesn't really matter their
entire business
is preying on flaws in the critical
infrastructure
of all the software running on the most
popular devices in the world
the number one target right is the
iphone and this is because the iphone
as secure as it is relative to a lot of
other phones
is a monoculture right like if you if
you have an iphone
you get these little software update
notifications all the time that are like
hey please update to the
the most recent version of ios and
that's a fabulous thing that's a
wonderful thing for security
because the number one way that people's
devices get screwed if it's not just
through user error
right like you entering your password
somewhere you shouldn't it's like a fake
site
it looks like gmail but it's not
actually gmail you just gave the guy
your password now he uses your password
to log in
but to actually break into a device is
that it's not
patched right patch means getting these
uh
security updates these little code
updates
that fix holes that researchers found in
the security device
well apple's really good about rolling
these out all the time for everybody in
the world the problem is
basically all these different iphones
right you got an iphone 6 you got an
iphone 8 you got an iphone x you got an
iphone you know
three whatever these are all running
a pretty narrow band of uh
software versions and so these guys go
if they want to target for example
android phones like google phones like a
samsung galaxy or something like that
there's like a billion different phones
made by a billion different people
half of them are completely out of date
but
what it means is it's not one version of
software they're running it's like 10
000 and this is actually bad for
security on the individual level
but it's good for security in a very
unusual way which is the guys who are
developing the exploits
the guys like this nso group who are
trying to find ways to break
into phones they now have to have like
50 different handsets running 50
different versions of software they're
all changing they've got different
hardware they've got
different chip sets for like they've got
different like all kinds of just
technical variables
that can screw up the way they attack uh
your phone and then when they find one
it only works on like this samsung
galaxy
line it doesn't work on like the google
pixel line or it doesn't work on like a
nokia line or something like that
whereas they realize if they find a way
to attack an iphone
which is actually you know this is
difficult this is really difficult stuff
now it works against basically every
iphone
and who has iphones all the rich people
right all the important people all the
lawmakers all the the guys who are in
there
so they've made a business on basically
attacking the iphone
and selling it to every two-bit thug uh
who runs a police department in the
world
you know they sell this stuff to saudi
arabia they sell this to mexico
and there's a group of researchers in
canada uh working at a university called
the citizen lab
and uh these guys are really like the
best in the world at tracking what
nso group is doing if you want to learn
about this stuff the real stuff
look up citizen lab and the nso group uh
and what they have found uh is
all the people who are being targeted um
by the nso group the classes of people
the countries that are using this
and you know it's not like the local
police department in germany
trying to bust up you know a terrorism
ring or something like that
it's the mexican government spying on
the head of the mexican opposition
we're trying to look at human rights
defenders who are investigating like
student disappearances
or it's people like the friends and
associates of jamal khashoggi
uh who was murdered by the saudi
government or it's
people like dissidents in bahrain and
these
like petro states uh these bad actors
nationally will pay
literally tens of millions of dollars
each year just to have the ability to
break into an iphone for a certain
number of times because that's how these
guys uh do it they sell their business
plan they go
we'll let you break in any iphone uh
just by basically sending a text message
to this phone all you need to find is
the phone number or a person who's
running an iphone
uh and we will exploit something uh
which will give you total if that
happens to someone
i'm sorry but if that happens to someone
could they
just get a new phone and does the
exploit is the exploit
specific to their account or is the
exploit on the
the physical phone so the question or
the answer to this is it really depends
on the exploit
like the easiest uh forms of exploit or
rather the easier
types of exploits are where they send
you a text message right and it'll be
like an imessage or something like that
and it's got a link in it that'll be
like oh gosh terrible news you know your
buddy's father just died
um and we're making funeral arrangements
are you gonna be there
it's the day after tomorrow and when you
click the link for the funeral
arrangements it
opens your web browser and the web
browser on your phone
is always the biggest most complicated
process in it right
there's a zillion lines of code in this
as opposed to an instant messenger where
there's fewer lines of code in it
and they'll find one thing in that where
there's a flaw
that lets them feed instructions not
just to the browser
but basically escape the little sandbox
that the browser's supposed to plan
that's supposed to be safe where it
can't do anything too harmful
and it'll run out of this sandbox and
it'll ransack
your your phone's like hard-wired
operating system uh the the system image
it'll like give them uh privileges
to do whatever they want on your phone
as if they are you
and then as if they have a higher level
of privilege than you they have system
level privileges
to change the phone's operation
permanently right and this
is the problem is on the phone you can
replace the phone
right and they'll lose access to that
but if they've already used that
to gain the passwords that you use to
access you know your icloud or whatever
when they have controlled the phone
they've already got your photo roll
right they've already got your contact
list they already have everything that
you've ever
put in that phone they already have all
your notes they already have all your
files they already have everything
that's in your message history right
they can pull that out
immediately and now not because they
have
you know all your contacts and things
like that they see that phone stop being
active
they know you've changed your phone
number all they have to do is find the
new phone number and then they can try
to go after you again
the benefit is uh with that old style of
attack
if you get that message and you don't
click that link you're
somebody in a vulnerable class right
you've had these kind of attacks
answered before it looks suspicious
you don't know who this person is the
number isn't right something like that
and you save that link you don't click
the link you don't do anything with that
link but you send it
to a group like citizen lab uh they can
basically use that link to
basically use uh like a dummy phone like
a sort of a trojan horse to go to the
site
that would attack your phone and catch
it and this is what the
sort of process that all of their
research is based on
there are other different types of
attacks that actually don't have these
defenses against them that are far
more scary but the bottom line is can i
stop you for a second
what is citizen lab citizen lab you just
said yeah the citizen lab is the name of
this research group at the university in
canada uh who basically studies
state-sponsored and corporate malware
attacks against civil society
it's ron run by a guy named ron dieber i
believe
you guys will have to fact check me on
that one i think he just published a
book
actually or is publishing a book about
all of this
but it's really they are the the world
leaders uh in my opinion
in uh basically investigating these kind
of attacks and exposing them
it's true public service um
let's go back to that one thing i asked
you about warrants and you talked about
the fact that like people could plant
evidence on things and then get
motivation
or um rather they could show probable
cause
right to the court to then investigate
you um and then they can get everything
and you said you know
you thought that uh a warrant man they
can go and search your house and this is
the kind of thing that we you know
modern people are used to thinking of in
the context of a warrant
cops go to a specific place looking for
specific things uh that are elements of
a crime
now you know you you've heard all these
things where like
cops find a way to like stop somebody
and they like are like oh i smelled pot
or whatever and they try to you know
toss their car or whatever
or plain sight doctrines where they open
the door and the guy sits down talks and
they go
you know i see a bong or something you
know that's paraphernalia you're going
to jail
but uh until i think it was 1967
warrants in the united states could only
be used
to gather two things they were called
the fruits and instrumentalities
of a crime which meant even if the cops
knew you did it
even if cops knew you you know rode the
subway or worked for this company or
whatever
they couldn't get all the company's
records uh they couldn't if they existed
uh get all the emails that you ever
wrote they couldn't get
your friend to turn over like an
exchange of letters that you had with
this person
the fruits of the crime were the things
that they gained from it right if they
robbed the bank
the cops could get the sack of money the
instrumentalities were the tools that
were used right like if you
used dynamite or a crowbar or a getaway
car
they could seize all of those things uh
but
the idea that the cops can get
everything
the idea that the fbi can get all these
records you know
all of these things your whole history
is very much
a new thing and nobody talks about that
today
we we just presume it's normal we
presume it's okay
but between 1967 and today think about
how many more
records there are about your life and
how things
like how you live private things about
you that have nothing to do with
criminality
and everything to do with the intimacy
of of who you are
and the fact that all of that now today
is exposed and not just to
let's say you love the us government
let's say you you know you
you are like throwing cookouts for your
local police department
but every other government in the world
too
and we really need to ask ourselves how
much
information uh do the authorities of the
day
need to do their job right how much do
we want them to have how much is proper
and appropriately
and necessary and how much is too much
and if we decide the cops shouldn't have
this if we decide the spies shouldn't
have this
well why in the hell should facebook or
google or somebody trying to
sell you nikes why should they have this
yeah um and what's the answer to that
they shouldn't yeah i mean right but
nobody wants to go backwards
once you have gained a certain amount of
access and you could
justify that access like we're stopping
crimes like the patriarch
and then which later the patriot act two
which was even
more overreaching once they have that
kind of power
they never go you know what we went too
far
we we have too much access to your
privacy
and even if you've committed a crime we
shouldn't have
unrelated access to all these other
activities that you're involved in
yeah and i mean that's exactly the thing
about the whole save the puppies act
right if it's got a name
like that you gotta be like no there's
something doesn't smell right here this
is
this is this there's something bad in
this and i mean
this so this gets back to uh
that uh initial topic of
uh what what did the court decide right
so we had the patriot act and the
patriot act was this giant law
that had been been written long before 9
11.
it was just sitting on the shelf uh and
the department of justice the fbi
they knew they couldn't pass this they
knew nobody would live with it
because it was an extreme expansion of
government authority
and then 9 11 happened right and that's
really where it all started to go wrong
that's where we got the rise of this new
authoritarianism
that we see continuing in the united
states today right like
if you think and you know like you have
problems with
what's happening under donald trump but
you also had problems under like what
was happening with obama and the
expansion of the war on whistleblowing
uh you had problems with the way drone
strikes were going out of control
you go well really where did this all
start right where did it start to go
wrong
personally i think 911
was where we made a fundamental mistake
and that was we were so frightened in
the movement because we had had such an
extraordinary and rare terrorist attack
uh succeed which by the way could have
been present
prevented and i think we discussed this
in the last episode
the congress you know they were they
were just terrified they said look
intelligence services
cops fbi whoever anything you want blank
check here you go
that was the patriot act and at the time
groups like the american civil liberties
union
they were like uh
we are worried that this goes too far
because god bless them that's what the
american civil liberties union does
and one of the provisions that they had
a problem with was this section 215
of the patriot act uh
which i believe they were calling at the
time the library records provision
and what it said basically this tiny
little little uh phrase
in the law said the fbi can basically
get
any records that it deems relevant to a
counter on terrorism investigation under
a warrant
and the worst thing the aclu could
imagine
was that these guys would go to the
library and get what kind of books
you're reading and like oh
shock horror this is the worst thing
these guys could do
and so they protested then they lost and
this passed and it went on
and lo and behold 10 years later
we find out in 2013 they had used uh
this provision
that people were worried about just
going after individuals library records
to instead get the phone records of not
an individual not a group
but everybody in the united states
who was making calls on u.s
telecommunications providers delivered
to the nsa daily
by these companies right so no matter
who you were no matter how innocent you
were
the fbi was getting these because they
said well every phone call
is relevant to a counter-terrorism
investigation and the court went
finally you know this is seven years
after 2013.
then with guys that's too much if your
definition of relevance is basically
anything anywhere all the time is
relevant to a counter-terrorist
investigation
the question is what then is not
relevant
what is the limiting principle on this
what where is the end
and this is a very important thing
because even if it's not enough right
even if this doesn't shut down all the
programs the program was actually
already stopped a few years ago
because of previous court decisions and
changes in law
the fact that the courts are finally uh
beginning to look at these
the the impacts of these sweeping new
technologies that allow
governments to see all of these
connections and interactions that we're
having every day
they're finally putting limits on it and
that is i think transformative
uh it is the foundation of what we will
see in the future will begin to
be the first meaningful
guarantees of privacy rights in the
digital age
now that you have been uh at least
according to
this court exonerated or justified
what what happens to you and
what happens to what they've been doing
and how how much of the breaks do they
hit on this
like how what changes does anything
change in the government's sweeping
surveillance
it's it's a great question i mean you
would think
uh when
you get a court not even a first level
court but an appeals court
that looks at these issues you know
they're talking about serious stuff
they're talking about counter-terrorism
investigations by the way in the same
thing
uh in the same decision they said the
government
has been arguing you know for 20 years
now these programs were saving lives
they were stopping terrorist attacks
they said uh
you know first they said mass
surveillance had stopped 54 terrorist
attacks in the united states
then they dropped it to seven and then
they dropped it to one
and the one terrorist attack uh or uh
terrorist conspiracy whatever that they
said it did stop
was this case that was just decided
and the court found and this is
important after
looking at the government's classified
evidence so this is not just the court
deciding on their own
this is the government going look here's
all the evidence that we have
the top secret stuff the stuff that
nobody can see please don't
you know say our program is ineffective
or whatever the court looked at it
and they went holy crap it did
this invasion of hundreds of millions of
americans privacy
happening over the span of decades did
not make a difference
in this case they said even if
or even in the absence of this program
if it hadn't existed the government had
never done it
they still would have busted this ring
because they were already closing in on
them the fbi
already had all the evidence they needed
to get a warrant to get the records
through traditional means
and the fact the government had been
saying congress had been saying for
years and years and years that this
program was necessary
uh the governor the court says that was
misleading
which is legalese for saying the
government's effing liars
on this uh so that raises the question
of okay like as you said
well what now how does this change
everything well it does mean the
government has to stop
doing this particular kind of program
directly but that program had already
shut down
and the government has a really great
team
of lawyers uh for every agency right the
doj has got lawyers the white house has
lawyers the fbi has lawyers the nsa has
lawyers and the cia has lawyers
and the only thing these guys are paid
to do all day
is to look at basically these legal
opinions from the court
that says all the ways the government
broke the law and go huh
is there any way we can just rejigger
this program slightly
so that we can dodge around that court
ruling
to go all right you know uh the abuses
are still happening
but they're happening in a less abusive
way and and then it's business as usual
so this is always the process um
with the court's uh ruling against the
government this is not an exceptional
uh thing in the case of the you know
it's nsa and cia
what happens is when the government
breaks the law
as the court has ruled them to do last
week
there is no punishment right there is no
criminal liability
uh for all the bastards at the head of
the fbi the head of the nsa
um who were violating americans rights
for decades those guys don't go to
prison
they don't lose their jobs they don't
even see the inside you know smell the
inside of a courtroom
where they're the ones wearing handcuffs
and because of that it creates a culture
of unaccountability of impunity right
which means with each generation of
government officials they study this
they study the cases against them they
study where they won they study where
they lost
and what they do is they try to create
exactly what just happened
which is a system where they can break
the law
for 10 years you know 2001 uh to 2013
basically
and no one even knows that it's
happening classification protects that
right
then eventually it gets exposed there's
a leak of course somebody blows the
whistle on it right
it becomes a scandal the government you
know they'll disown this program they'll
change the law there
but somebody like the aclu
will sue the government and so the
courts will finally
be forced to look at these things but
the wheels of justice turn slow right
the government will try to put the
brakes on it um
the plaintiffs the civil society
organizations that are suing
will have to gather evidence it's really
difficult to do because the government's
not providing anything it's all
classified
and then basically it takes another five
years another 10 years for the court to
get to their verdict
and then we have it but then nobody goes
to jail right nobody actually faces
serious consequences who is responsible
for the wrongdoing
and so the cycle continues but having
said that
like it might feel disempowering might
people might go oh we can't win
but this is in the context of a system
where we lack
accountability where the government does
have a culture of impunity
this is what winning looks like because
things do get better
the problem is they get better by
decades they get better by half
centuries and centuries
if you look at the united states you
know 200 years ago 100 years ago
things were objectively worse on
basically every measure
the fact that we have to crawl to the
future
is a sad thing when we know it could be
fixed
very quickly by establishing some kind
of criminal liability for people like
james clapper the former director of
national intelligence
who lied under oath to congress and the
american people saying
exactly this program didn't exist
the nsa wasn't collecting any
information on millions or hundreds of
millions of americans
when in fact they were doing that every
day
obama did not fire him right obama did
not charge him obama let him serve out
the end of his days and then retire
happily
but it's not an obama problem right
we see the same kinds of abuses
happening under the trump administration
we saw the same kind of abuses
happening under the bush administration
and the only way this changes
um materially is if our government
changes structurally right and that's
kind of the issue that i think everybody
in the country sees
when you look at the economy when you
look at all the struggle when you look
at all the class conflict and divide and
the political
partisanship that's happening today
the problem isn't right like about this
law or this court ruling or this agency
it's about inequality of opportunity of
access
uh even of privilege right i know people
don't like talking about that
it's uncomfortable for people like oh my
god you know are you like whatever
but the reality is we have a few people
in the country
you know the jeff bezos the bill gates
that own
everything like 10 people owning half
the country
and half the country owning nothing at
all
and this applies to influence
right when you have that kind of
disproportionality
uh of resources you have that kind of
of influence your vote means less your
ability to
change the law means less your access to
the courts
means less and that's how we end up in
the situation where we are today
that's very disheartening well it
doesn't have to be because the important
thing is we can change it
can we though i mean like what can we do
and what can anybody change this point
to stop this overwhelming
power that the government has to
invade your privacy and to all the
things that you exposed
when you talk about how the particular
program that was in place has been shut
down but all they do
is manipulate it slightly do it so that
you can argue in court that it's not the
same thing
that is a different thing come up with
other justifications for it
and withhold evidence and then drag the
process
out for years and years and years and to
for you to be so optimistic is really
kind of spectacular considering the fact
that you've been
hiding in another country allegedly we
don't even know you might be in ohio
we don't know you know we don't know
like but but
but you are essentially on the lamb and
for exposing something that has now been
determined to be
illegal so you are correct when you go
back to obama's hope and
uh what was his uh his website
hope and change hope and change a big
part of hope and change
was protecting whistleblowers do you
remember that and that was all
deleted later later on they were like
yeah let's go back and take that [ __ ]
out we didn't know i didn't know what it
was like to actually be president back
then i was just
trying to get in there but the hope and
change stuff was still
there when you were being tried was
still there when they were chasing you
and and and trying to find your location
when the guardian article came out the
hope and change [ __ ] was still
still online yeah and that's the fact
that you're so optimistic
even though you've been [ __ ] over
royally i mean you are
in my opinion you're a hero i really
think that
and i really and i really think that
what what you exposed
is hugely important for uh
the american citizens to understand that
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
these people
had uh the ability to look into
everything and they just still do
they have the ability to look into
everything you're doing and
the fact that through these years it
literally stopped zero terrorist attacks
zero so this sweeping
overwhelming intrusion of your privacy
had no impact whatsoever on your safety
well it wasn't about safety it was about
power right
they told us it was about safety that
was
again it's the save the puppies act um
if you uh
if you see government saying all these
things are for safety they're protecting
you
and they never establish the efficacy of
it
the chances are there it probably isn't
effective
because you know the government leaks
all the time um you know if they say
uh we saved this person we did that you
know whenever they're being criticized
they go on tv and they
very seriously go oh that's classified
and you know we can't expose that and
you never hear of the successes we do
because it's so important that they stay
secret
look i worked for the cia i worked for
the nsa that's [ __ ]
um when they do something great you know
it's on the front page of the new york
times by the end of the day
because they're fighting for budget
they're fighting for clout they're
fighting for authority they're fighting
for new laws not constantly
uh and so there are no real
accomplishments that are
in the shadows that they just don't tell
us i mean very rarely think about when
we got bin laden
right you know obama was like i want a
press conference within the next
20 minutes and again this is not to bag
on obama
any president would do this um that's
just
how it is now of course there are
some uh secret successes but it's about
stuff that no one cares about it's stuff
that wouldn't win the political clout
it's like
they gained an advantaged negotiating
position on the price of
shrimp and clove cigarettes which was
actually one of the stories that came
out of some kind of
uh classified disclosure that i think
was from from wikileaks
that kind of stuff it actually does
happen right
but we're never having a conversation of
do you want to give up
all of your privacy rights so that we
can get better prices on shrimp and
clove cigarettes
like that would be a very different
political conversation than
do you want to give up all of your
privacy rights because if you don't your
children
will die and you know
you know it saved the puppies right
exactly save the puppies 20 20.
um so this
this thing you ask about uh you know me
and
optimism like i have been criticized
relentlessly
uh for being a naive optimist right um
and my answer is that you don't
do what i did unless you believe that
people can do better
i took a very comfortable life you know
i was living in hawaii with the woman
that i loved i had to do basically no
work but go in the office and read spy
feeds about people uh you know all day
long
um and i could have done that you know
for the rest of my life quite happily
would have been great
um i set that on fire because
i believed that what i saw was wrong and
i believe that people deserve to know
about it and i believe that if people
did know about it that things would
change
i did not believe it was going to save
the world i did not believe
i was going to get you know a ticker
tape parade and a pardon you know be
welcomed with open arms there's actually
if you watch citizen 4
which is the documentary from 2013 where
i was meeting with reporters
laura poitras had the camera rolling in
the room when we talked for the first
time
um i said you know the government's
gonna
say i harm national security i put
everybody in jeopardy they're gonna
charge me under the espionage act
uh and they really did try to destroy my
life they tried to put me in prison
forever
and to this day they are still trying to
do uh
the same thing that's just how it is you
know this wasn't like
even though even though yeah even though
the the most recent ruling has showed
that you were correct
and what they were doing was illegal and
you exposed a crime yeah well i mean
this is this is a
a continuing story in 2013 uh
you know when this first came out uh
president obama went out on stage uh
you know because he was getting singed
in the press
and said uh you know uh take it from me
nobody is listening to your phone calls
uh even though nobody says just metadata
yeah nobody said they were
listening to your phone calls it wasn't
like they had headsets on
uh you know 300 plus million people in
the united states
you'd have to have computers do that um
but what they did do was they collected
the records of your phone calls and to
an
analyst an intelligence analyst that's
more very valuable
than the transcripts your phone calls we
care less
about what you said on the phone then
who you called
when you called them what else you were
doing what your phone was doing right
the websites that you would access the
cell phone towers they were connected to
all of those things that metadata
creates what's called the social graph
your pattern of life
it says based on when your phone becomes
active in the morning when you start
calling people when you start browsing
when you check your
you know twitter feed you're scrolling
on instagram whatever
that's when you wake up when it stops
that's when you go to sleep
we see where you are we see where you
live we see who you live with
all of those things right that's just
from metadata you don't need the content
of your communications i don't need to
see
what picture you posted on instagram
to know you're awake and active and
you're communicating with this
person uh at this phone this place this
area code this ip address you know this
version of software whether they're
using android or ios you know all of
these
things and now as we get smartphones as
your cars
begin connecting to the internet uh it's
just richer and richer and richer data
i don't know where i was going with that
sorry i got off topic but
um the
the bottom line is things get better
they get
better slowly all right sorry now obama
was saying you know nobody listens to
your phone calls right
that was june 2013. by january of 2014
giving a state of the union address
he went although he could never condone
what i did the conversation that i
started has made us stronger as a nation
he was calling for the end of this
program the passage of a new law
called the usa freedom act another save
the puppies act
uh which was better than the thing it
was replacing but still really bad
um and he did that not out of the
goodness of his heart
he did that because the court in
december of 2013
had ruled these programs were unlawful
and likely unconstitutional
and this is again it's not an obama
thing it's a power thing this is how the
system works right
but year by year step by step things get
better we make progress a little bit at
a time and the fact that
someone is suing the fact that the aclu
is bringing this case and we should
thank them for that
for years which is a difficult and
expensive proposition with no guarantee
of success
means that we have stronger privacy
result rights
seven years later as a result that
doesn't mean
we save the world that doesn't mean we
relax we sit down on the couch you know
there's the golden sunset
that's not how life works it is a
constant struggle
but when we do struggle when we do stand
up we believe in something so strongly
we don't
merely believe in it uh but we risk
something for that belief uh we work
together and we
pulled the species forward an inch at a
time
we move away from that swamp of impunity
and unaccountability
uh into a future where hey maybe not
just a little guy
breaks the law and goes to jail but
maybe
a senator maybe an attorney general
a president right and that would be a
very good precedent to have
do you wonder whether or not someone
will
use you as a political chess piece
at this point and decide i mean i i
believe if
correct me if i'm wrong but i'm pretty
sure you have overwhelming support of
the general public
most people believe that what you did
was was a good thing for america
and that you are in fact a patriot i i
think the vast majority people
and the people that i've talked to i
have talked to a few people that
disagree with that
they're misinformed they were
misinformed about what you did and what
information you were leaked or whether
or not people's
lives were put in danger because of that
and i had to explain
the whole chain of events and where the
information actually
was how it was leaked and what you had
done
to protect people there's there's a
could you plea please explain
that because it wasn't just that the
information was dumped
yeah so i mean this is really the
subject of our our our last conversation
goes on for three hours but i wrote a
book
yeah but i just would just so this will
stand alone i'm yeah
i'll go through it so uh the idea and
this is the subject of my first book
permanent record which was why i came on
last year and actually
uh just this week the soft cover came
out so it's more affordable
for people who didn't want to get it
before um
is this story right it's who i am where
i came from why i did this
how and what it meant i didn't just
reveal information i gave it to
journalists right
these journalists were only given access
to the information on the condition that
they would publish
no story simply because it was
newsworthy or interesting right they
weren't going to click bait classified
documents
they would only publish stories if they
were willing to make an independent
institutional judgment and stand by it
that it was in the public interest that
this be known right
and then as an extraordinary measure on
top of that before they publish the
stories right and this is
not me publishing things putting them
out on the internet or blog or something
which i could have done would have been
very easy
uh it's not me telling them what to
write or not to write they're
doing this the guardian the washington
post you know der spiegel
they are then going to the united states
government in advance of publication
and giving the government a chance an
adversarial opportunity to
argue against publication to go you guys
don't get it you know
snowden's a liar these documents are
false or
he's not lying and yes these are true
but these programs are effective they're
saving lives whatever
and here's what we can show you to
convince you please don't publish this
or leave out this detail
and in every case i'm aware of that
process was followed and that's why
now in 2020 remember we're seven years
on from 2013. the government has never
shown a single example of any harm that
has come as a result of the publication
of these documents back in 2013 the
revelation of mass surveillance
and it's that's what i wanted to bring
yeah and i mean
it's unscientific uh but i've seen polls
run on twitter
uh very recently uh in the last few
weeks when this pardon question came out
where 90 like 90 plus percent of people
were in favor of a pardon and that's
crazy
uh even in 2013 when we were doing well
you know it was like 60 percent
um in favor among young people but it
was like 40 percent for older people
but that's because the government was on
tv every sunday you know bringing these
uh
cia suits going uh who were there with
their very stern
faces going oh this caused great damage
and cost lives and everything like that
but those arguments stopped being
convincing when
seven years later after they told us and
the sky is falling
the atmosphere never catches fire right
the oceans never boil off we're still
alive
uh and i i think people can see through
that and that was
again this exactly what you said people
don't know
this history uh that that 10 percent who
are against it
and actually a lot of the 90 who are
even in favor of it
um they don't know the details it wasn't
well covered by the media at the time it
was all about this person said that that
person said that is it true is it false
you know
sort of uh they were playing on
character
they were trying to make a drama out of
it and that's a big part of why i wrote
permanent record
uh and it's been tremendously gratifying
to see
people connect to it and actually this
uh you know i mentioned it
uh we talked on on twitter when we were
talking about the possibility of having
this conversation
and i was like i looked back at our
first conversation we had
and it's had like 16 million views
man that's for a three hour conversation
uh i like set
and then probably an equal amount of
people just listen to it in audio
right and that that was just for one
clip on youtube
there were smaller clips like talking
about cell phone surveillance and that
was like another 10 million views
77 000 comments uh the book on amazon
has
thousands of reviews it's got a 4.8
rating which
like by the number of people and how
it's rated
that's one of the best autobiographies
according to ordinary people the
audience
in like years and to see that after
these years of attacks
to me is evidence that despite all these
news guys
uh at night going well senator you know
uh
no one really cares about privacy these
days these kids with their facebooks and
their instagrams
uh you know people do care
what they're actually feeling is kind of
what you got to earlier with like this
sensation that nothing changes
like even when we win we lose but the
thing is you've got to have
a broader view of time
you've got to look at the sweep of
history rather than the atmosphere of
the moment
because right now yes things are very
bad
and even if you love donald trump
because i know some of your viewers do
you got to admit a lot of things in the
world suck right now a lot of things in
the country
suck right now but the thing is they
only get better
if somebody does the hard work to make
them better
and there's no magic wand there's no
happy ending right life is not that
simple but together
we can make it better and we do that
through
struggle do you
uh has there been any discussion about
someone pardoning you
has there been i mean this was the
question initially that led to this
but i wanted you to expand on what would
actually went down but
has there been any discussion about you
being pardoned or someone using you as
like i said a political chess piece
because you it
would be a smart thing and if anybody
has had a problem with the intelligence
community it is donald trump
i mean he's the only president in our in
any memory
that has had open disagreements and been
openly disparaging of the intelligence
community well that's not true
it was jfk but that didn't go very well
that's right
i forgot about that good point yeah that
that went terrible for him
uh for trump for trump it actually seems
to be a positive in some strange way
um if anybody is going to pardon you i
would imagine
that would be the guy so this idea of
like the political bargaining chip
has actually been used in a different
way uh there was the idea
um and it's funny because this was
actually promoted by all these like cia
deputy directors and whatnot
who were responsible for these abuses of
americans rights
who were writing opinion pieces in the
newspaper and they were like you know
what if vladimir putin you know sends
snowden to trump as like an inauguration
gift
wouldn't that be terrible for him and
they were like intent
you know um but i don't think
when we talk about this stuff uh
i i don't think there's anything i can
do to control one of the things people
have asked is like would i accept
a pardon uh from donald trump and i
think that
apprehends what a pardon is and how it
works
uh pardon's not a contract a pardon is
not something that you agree to
uh pardon is a constitutionally
enumerated power
i think it's article two section two um
where the reason that it exists
uh is basically a check on the laws and
the judiciary
uh where the laws as written become
corrosive to the intention
of them and this is something that i
think actually is meaningful you know
people are like are you gonna ask
uh donald trump for a pardon and the
answer is is no
um but i will ask for pardon
for terry albert and daniel hale and
reality winner
and all the other american
whistleblowers who have been treated
unfairly by this system
the whole thing that brought this up was
two weeks ago some journalists
asked the president like oh you know
what do you think about snowden are you
going to pardon him
and he said he seemed to be thinking
about it he heard i have been treated
very unfairly
that's accurate because it's impossible
to get a fair
trial uh under the espionage act which
is what i've been charged under
and every american whistleblower since
daniel ellsberg in the 1970s has been
charged
under this law the espionage act which
makes no distinction between someone
who is stealing secrets and selling them
to foreign governments
which neither i nor any of these other
people have done
and giving them freely to journalists
to advance the public interest of the
american people
rather than the private interests of
these spies you know
individually and this is the kind of
uh this is the kind of circumstance for
which
the pardon power exists where the courts
and judges will not or cannot
end a fundamentally unfair and abusive
circumstance in the united states either
because they're uh
fearful of being criticized of soft on
terrorism or whatever
uh or because the law prohibits them
from doing so the the problem with the
espionage act
is it means you can't tell the jury why
you did what you did
you cannot mount what's called a public
interest offense
where you say hell yeah i broke the law
i took a classified document and i gave
it to the journalist and the journalist
published it and then it went to the
courts and the court said
this guy was right the government was
breaking the law
in the courts if i were you know in in
prison today uh
as reality winners in prison today or
rather daniel hale
uh who revealed uh government abuses
related to the drone program or
terry albury who revealed
problems with uh racial policies in the
fbi
how they were being abused um when these
guys are on trial
all of that stuff is forbidden from
being spoken
daniel ellsberg's lawyer uh asked daniel
ellsberg
why did you do it in court in open court
under oath you know why did you publish
or provide
journalists the pentagon papers and the
prosecutor said objection objection he
can't say that
and the judge said sustained fine he
can't say it and his attorney looked at
the judge like he was crazy and said
i've never heard
of a trial where the jury is not allowed
to hear
why uh a defendant did what they did
and the judge said well you're seeing
one now
and this is why the pardon power exists
well that's what's so creepy about
something like the espionage espionage
act
if if you can't even establish a motive
you can't even explain
that you were doing this for the
american people that there's a real
precedent that should be set for for
this kind of thing especially
in regards to what you're being charged
with which has now been determined
that you were exposing something that
was in fact illegal
and this is it's it's it's an incredibly
un-american thing it's it's very
un-american
it really is but this is it's
disturbingly so i mean we see these kind
of injustices happening in the united
states every day and it's not about the
espionage act specifically i mean you
see with drug charges you see it with
civil forfeiture
asset forfeiture where like you know
they take an old lady's car because her
nephew was selling weed or something
like that
and there's no way for her to get it
back whether we're talking civil whether
we're talking federal whether we're
talking um
sorry civil or criminal whether we're
talking federal or state
we see where the system of laws in the
united states
is letting people down constantly
uh but the question becomes how do we
fix this how does that get addressed and
you know you can mount a national
campaign you can try to change the law
but as we talked about
before unless you're unless you're jeff
bezos unless you're bill gates that's
very difficult to do
but the governor can pardon people for
state crimes the president can pardon
people for federal crimes but we have
not
developed a compassionate culture that
actually looks at this
like every president has abused their
pardon power
or their pardon authority to sort of let
their cronies
off the hook we've seen this president
we've seen in the previous presidents
sure but it is very difficult to
establish
an understanding among average people uh
that it's actually okay for presidents
to use this power more liberally
when particularly we're talking about
non-violent offenses when we're talking
about things
uh that have not you know uh they're not
that controversial but they are being
controversialized because of the
political atmosphere of partisanship
where everything has to be criticized
for political advantage from one side or
the other everything's become a football
well particularly in your case when
you're talking about polls that show
90 percent of people support you being
pardoned
and this recent ruling that what you
exposed was illegal
i wonder how much the president actually
knows about your case
you know because it's a good question i
mean he's
famous for barely paying attention in
briefings and
you know i mean i just i can't imagine
that in 2013
this was fully on his radar where he
investigated it and read all the
documents and really got
deep into it i i can't imagine he really
knows
everything that went down i bet he
hasn't seen citizen four i mean i bet i
sure i
really you know what i mean
listen if i had his number i really
would um and i i do know
people who know him and i am going to
communicate that
uh after this conversation i think that
would be
i literally think that would win him a
tremendous amount of political favor
i really do i think particularly at this
point in time
where people are really look if there's
ever a time where people are fed up
about the overreaching
power of government it's during this
pandemic lockdown
you know for good or for bad whether
it's incorrect or incorrect
people are very frustrated right now
with power
they're very frustrated right now with
the draconian measures that some states
have put in place to keep people from
working and
and their eyes keep people safe and all
this
would contribute to the motivation
to uh to pardon you because i think that
it would show people that the president
actually does agree that there have been
some overreaches and in your case
not just an overeat but a miscarriage of
justice
a disgusting unamerican overreach
i think when you ask this question about
like
how much does he know about the case
it's fair to say
not a lot because he's intentionally
being misadvised
by his advisors you've had the attorney
general william barr who says he would
be you know vehemently opposed to a
pardon for me
uh his secretary of state mike pompeo
has literally i i think said i should be
killed john bolton at least said i
should be killed
um and you know i i think when this
conversation first came up a couple
weeks ago mike pompeo probably
hid every pen in the white house because
he's trying to make sure things like
this don't happen i think there are a
lot of people
uh who try and control the president
but this whole question about you know
uh
what's right for me uh what's right for
the president in terms of political
advantage
is is the wrong question this is why i
haven't been advocating for pardon i
didn't ask for
a pardon from obama i did ask for a
pardon for chelsea manning
which we didn't get but we did get
clemency uh and that's an important
thing
because what we need
is we need for pardons to be made not as
a question of political advantage
uh but as a decision taken
on uh to further the public interest and
this is why i say
pardon you know all of these previous
whistleblowers uh
uh thomas drake john kiriakou terry
albury reality winner daniel hale
there are many names daniel ellsberg
right he wasn't convicted so he got out
but these people deserve recognition as
the patriots who stood up and took a
risk
for the rest of us that they are look at
the the current cases right that don't
even require an exercise of the pardon
at the party
but julian assange right now today
is in court in the uk fighting an
extradition trial to the united states
for those who don't remember
this is the guy who's the head of
wikileaks right and he really fell out
of favor
in 2016 because he published the hillary
emails and everything like that or
podesta emails
but he's not being charged for that the
extradition trial has nothing to do with
that
actually the us government uh under
william barr
right the current attorney general is
trying to extradite this guy
and put him in prison for the rest of
his life for the best
work that wikileaks ever did that has
won awards in every country
basically around the planet including
the united states
which is the iraq and afghanistan war
logs right
detainee records in guantanamo bay
things that are about explicit war
crimes and abuses of power
torture and people who were killed who
should have been killed violations of
use of force protocols and all of these
things right
and this could all be made to go away if
william barr the attorney general simply
dropped the charges
and he should why isn't he
well julian assange has literally been
tortured
i mean the guy was locked in that
embassy for how many years with no
exposure to daylight just completely
trapped and
you've seen videos of him skateboarding
around the the embassy
he looks like he's going crazy in there
and now he's in jail and on trial
the whole thing is it's so disturbing
because
you know when it boils down to like what
what did he do
that is illegal what did he do that
people disagree with that people the
united states disagree with
in terms of the citizens well he he
exposed her horrific
crimes he exposed things that were
deeply uh that were that the united
states citizens are deeply opposed to
and the fact that that
is something that you in this country
can be uh prosecuted for that they would
try to extradite you
and and drag you from another country
they'd kick him out of the embassy and
bring him back to the united states
to try him for that it seems like we're
talking about some kangaroo court it
seems like we're talking about some
some dictatorship where you know you
have
these uh no protection of freedom of
speech
no protection under the first amendment
no no protection under
the the rights of the press it's just
it's so disturbing that there are
workarounds
for our constitution our bill of rights
that are
with that we all just agree to just
accept that this is happening there's no
riots in the streets for this
there's no no one's up in arms that
they're trying to extradite julian
assange no no
no one i mean it's not in the news like
for whatever reason the mainstream news
has
barely covered it over this uh his
current court proceedings in the
in the uk well i think a lot of this
comes down to the fact that
uh they see julian assange
by this day i mean the a lot of the
mainstream media the broadcast outlets
as a partisan figure now and it's really
sad because
the most dangerous thing about the
charges against julian assange
is if they extradite julian assange if
julian assange is convicted
he's charged under the espionage act the
same act that i'm charged under the same
thing that all these whistleblowers are
charged under
but he is not a source the way as
abusive as these espionage act charges
have run
in the last 50 years is the government
had
sort of a quiet agreement they never
charge the press outlets they never
charge the new york times they never
charge the washington post
they don't charge the journalists they
charge their sources
they charge the chelsea mannings right
they they charge the edward snowden's
they charge the thomas drake's the
daniel ellsbergs
but the press they're left alone they
are breaking that agreement with the
julian assange case
assange is not the source he is merely a
publisher
he runs a press organization people like
oh julian assange is not a journalist
he's not whatever
there is no way you can make that
argument in court
in a way that will be defensible
particularly given what we've talked
about with the government and how
careful they are to avoid
prior uh court precedents and to work
around it and create you know obscure
legal theories
that are legal fictions everyone knows
they're a lie everyone knows these
theories are false
but under the law you know they bend
just enough that they can pass the
argument through and get the conviction
they want
you cannot convict julian assange
the chief editor and publisher of
wikileaks
under the espionage act without exposing
the new york times the washington post
cbs abc nbc you know cnn fox whoever
to the same kind of charges under this
president and every coming president
and i think people don't think about
that
that that is disturbing you know another
thing that's disturbed well
there's many things that are disturbing
about this case but another thing that's
been disturbing was
he was a guy who the left supported
up until 2016 and then it became
inconvenient
right it was great then when he's
dragging yes
clinton it's not so great right right
when
when the the footage was revealed from
the
uh uh i i believe it was a helicopter
that showed it was
uh collateral murder remember that video
that was collapsing out
in iraq yeah it was a very helicopter in
iraq firing on two
reuters journalists uh yes
local militants or something yes exactly
um that was the left's
he was the darling of the left i mean
they were all
free julian assange and it's just it's
so interesting how that narrative can
shift so completely to all of a sudden
he's a puppet of russia
and that's what it became in 2016 and
that propaganda stuck
and people who were pro julian assange
before
now all of a sudden i i've i've seen
these people say [ __ ] wikileaks
you know and [ __ ] julian assange like
that guy he's a puppet of russia i'm
like
like how much have you looked into this
it's amazing
how that kind of propaganda when you
just get
the surface veneer of the the the
whatever the narrative there that is
they're trying to push how well it
spreads
that all these people who were these
educated
left-wing people now all of a sudden
were anti-wikileaks
and i'm like do you not remember how
this whole thing got started it was the
iraq war
which we all opposed do not remember
this whole
[ __ ] lie about the weapons of mass
destruction that got us into this crazy
war and then
julian assange and wikileaks exposed
so much of this and yet here we are
in 2016 it turns up on its head
and now he's a puppet of russia and
wikileaks is bad because
inconveniently the information that he
released damaged hillary clinton's
campaign
yeah i i think a lot of it comes down to
people forgetting uh what principles are
and why they're important yes right um
you can hate julian assange you can
think julian assange is a puppet of
russia you can think he's the worst
person on earth right he's a
reincarnation of hitler or stalin or
whatever
and still realize that convicting him
harms you it harms your society it harms
your children's future
people forget about this and today is a
world where everything's become partisan
but the aclu cut their teeth they they
made their reputation on defending a
nazi march
through a jewish neighborhood
and this is because it's about uh
the right to assembly the right to
freedom of speech you do not have a
right to be free
from offense right there is no uh
constitutional right to a safe space
but that doesn't mean you do nothing
that doesn't mean you have no opinion
that doesn't mean you have no political
power
what it does mean is that you have to
recognize that
everyone has the right to their own
opinion even
terrible opinions what we have to
protect is the speech is the platform is
the assemblies the association is the
process
that allows us to understand and
recognize and identify
when people did break the law when they
did harm others to go to a
fair trial where the jury can consider
why they did what they did
what they did and not just whether it
was legal
or illegal but whether it was moral or
immoral whether it was right
or whether it was wrong and whether they
are the lowest person
you know the the most ordinary citizen
in the country or the
highest elected official hold them to
the same standard of behavior the same
rule of law
whereas today you know we call them uh
public officials and
private citizens but with the all of the
surveillance all of the data collection
uh people in power commercially or
governmentally they know
everything about us and we know nothing
about them
uh we break the smallest law we go to
jail we get a fine we get screwed we
can't get a job we can't get a loan
uh but if they you know flagrantly abuse
their office
their authority uh they get a pass they
go on the speakers circuit you know
it's it's all uh sunshine and rainbows
for them
uh and the way we change these things is
remembering our principles of being
willing to stand and defend them
it's also instinctual for people to be
partisan
and it's tribal it's a tribal thing and
in this day and age people are
rabidly partisan and the rejection of
nuance is so disturbing to me
and it's so disturbing that a lot of
this happens from the left now
whereas the left used to be all about
freedom of speech the aclu is
i mean it's just you you automatically
think of
the liberal people when you think of the
aclu but
the academy just for the record is a
non-partisan organization
yes but supported overwhelmingly
certainly by by left-wing people
um i mean obviously they are nonpartisan
but
but people are so partisan today that
this rejection of nuance
it's it's so it's so easy for people
to look at things as left versus right
and ignore all of the sins of their team
and concentrate on defeating the other
side
and it seems to be a giant part of the
problem today
so much so that people are in favor
a lot of people are in favor of
de-platforming people
that just simply disagree with them and
i want to talk to you about that because
that seems to be a gigantic issue
not seems to be it is a gigantic issue
with social media
whether it's with twitter or youtube or
many things
um in fact unity 2020 is uh something
that
my friend my friend brett weinstein uh
is putting together
this idea that we should look
across both parties
for people that are reasonable and
rational people and look at what
we agree with rather than simply
sitting on on partisan policy
uh on on party lines and only voting
you know blue across the board or red
across the board and
let's look at reasonable people from
both sides whether it's dan crenshaw
and tulsi gabbard or who whoever it is
that are they represent different
parties but they're both reasonable
people let's get them together and have
these communications
they were banned from twitter they were
simply ban
banned from twitter for simply saying
reject
both trump and biden look for a third
choice
so this is not there's nothing offensive
about what they did
in fact they're they're encouraging
choice
they're encouraging this idea that we
don't have to be a two-party system
that in fact even though we have had
libertarian and green parties
we kind of look at it like [ __ ] it's
like a protest
vote if you vote green party you know
you're not going to elect that person
for president
it's kind of like we tolerate it but
when someone like ross perot came around
it threw a monkey wrench into the gears
and became very dangerous for both sides
because the republicans lost a lot of
votes and that's how bill clinton got
into office and george h.w bush
did not get a second term directly
because the influence of ross perot so
they changed
the requirements for getting into the
debates and everything became
very different and very more complicated
after that
the fact that they would that twitter
would be willing to ban
unity 2020 specifically because they're
calling
for people to walk away from this idea
that you have to either vote
for trump or biden and trying to get
mainstream acceptance of a potential
third party candidate
is extremely disturbing but deep
platforming in general
i think is extremely disturbing because
it's a slippery slope
if you decide that someone has views
that are
opposite of yours and they bother you
those views bother you
and you could do whatever you can to get
them off of a platform
it's very dangerous because someone
from the right who gains power or
someone from an opposing party that
gains power
if they get into a position of power in
social media
if they own gigantic social media
company like twitter or youtube
and they decide in turn to go after
people that
agree with your ideology well then we
have a freedom of speech issue
and you're you're literally supporting
the suppression of freedom of speech
if you're supporting deep platforming
people on social media
and i've always thought that the answer
to
someone saying something you disagree
with or something someone saying
something you vehemently oppose
is a better argument that's what they
it's supposed to be yeah it's supposed
to be you should expose the problems and
what they're doing
and i'm seeing so many people
particularly on the left that are
happy when people get de-platformed
and people that just are
just are contrary to their perspective
contrary to their ideology and
it's it's i think it's very dangerous
and it's too easy it's too easy to
accept it's
in this this goes back to what you're
saying this partisan
viewpoint that we have today fiercely
rabidly partisan
in a way that i've never seen in my life
yeah i
i think the question of d platforming
this is one of the the
central issues of our time that's really
overlooked and it's under-appreciated uh
so many people on both sides are in
favor of this
uh when it's somebody they don't like
right
yes
the central issue is this do we want
companies
deciding what can and cannot be said do
we want governments
deciding what can and cannot be said
if the answer is yes uh it is a very
different kind of society than
we have had traditionally i do think we
need to understand
uh where this impulse came from
how it came to be and why it seemed
reasonable and a lot of people
forget this and it came from isis
if you remember the islamic state it was
all over youtube they were all over
twitter they were all over facebook
and they were literally burning people
alive in cages they were beheading
people you know pushing people off
buildings just
horrible stuff um and that raises a
tough question for a lot of these
companies
now it's very easy to make the argument
that all right this is a direct call for
violence this is
literally uh supporting terrorism
um and as a private company we have no
obligation to let people use our
platforms
therefore we're closing their accounts
right we're shutting this off we're
erasing it we can do whatever we want
it's our website don't like it leave
um constitutionally there's no uh
freedom of speech
issue implicated there because the
constitution
restrains the federal government and the
state governments
in certain circumstances not
private companies but
once that precedent had been established
uh that they would do this for isis they
started going well what about these
other people uh what about these things
that could be construed as calls to
violence
okay what if they're not violence at all
what if it's harassment what if it's
abuse what if it's racism what if it's
you know criminality what if it's drug
culture what if it's pornography what if
it's whatever
and there will always be more what ifs
and the categories of prohibited speech
will
constantly expand so we need to ask
ourselves well who is best placed to
make those decisions about what can and
cannot be said
traditionally the
access to broadcast was limited
you had radio you had tv if you didn't
have that you had the soapbox on the
corner
right or the local university uh the
coffee shop
and somebody owned those places or
somebody ran those places
you know the college president would say
this person would be invited to speak
this person wouldn't be invited to speak
um and i actually think it's right and
proper
for people to be able to protest
speakers to say this person shouldn't
speak
at our college but i think the college
itself the institution
has to be willing to make value
judgments about why
they invite certain people to speak and
if that person is very unpopular
speaker if that person is uh
representing a viewpoint that is not
well supported by the college
uh if it's not necessarily what students
want to hear
but the administration believes like the
faculty believes
that it's something students should hear
isn't that why we have universities we
don't go to class
to learn you know necessarily like you
don't go to a literature course
to read the things that you want to read
you just go home and read those yourself
you go to study a curriculum to
something else you want to benefit from
the experience from the perspectives of
others
the question that people have is how
does this expand into the wider audience
right what happens when you move beyond
universities what happens when you move
to news broadcast what happens
when you move to the internet what
happens when everyone everywhere can
broadcast and this is where i think
things get really tricky
not can people say what they want as
long as they're not
advocating violence or whatever i don't
think this should be a difficult issue
but this gets complicated when you
have things like youtube's next video
suggestion
algorithm because the idea of
universal uh speech universal ability to
broadcast
is exactly as you said well what is the
counter for this you've got
freaking nazis on the internet and i'm
not talking
like whatever the guy's got a trump
sticker on his truck i'm talking
goose stepping you know swastika bearing
actual freaking nazi
um you have those people out there on
the internet calling for violence
calling for all these terrible
things and normally the way you deal
with this even in the case of something
like isis
you drag them onto the platform you
discredit their ideas before the world
because if you don't
if you drive them underground if you
make them you know this this faction
that's you know
hanging out at a radical mosque
or you know they're hanging out the
hardware store if they're freaking nazis
or whatever
there are uh places where you create its
own community that is sheltered from
other perspectives
it's sheltered from other ideas and that
is where
extremism thrives where it cannot be
challenged
where it cannot be exposed for what it
really is
but when you've got youtube going oh you
like nazi a
how about nazi b how about nazi c right
these people never get exposed to
counter speech and this is where things
get tricky
well it also gets tricky when you decide
that someone is saying something that's
offensive
and you remove them from the platform
and then you open the door
for other things being offensive things
that maybe aren't offensive to you
the the slope gets slippery and then you
have wrong speak you have
you have newly dictated language that
you have to use
you have new restrictions on
ideologies things you're not allowed to
espouse i mean
twitter will ban you for dead naming
someone they will ban you for life
meaning if you transition to be a woman
and you call yourself edwina and i call
you edward
you i will be banned for life with no
recourse
which is madness it's matt because i can
call you [ __ ] face
and no one has a problem with it yeah
you know what i'm saying i could call
you a terrible i could
i could call you that and there's no
problem but if i
you choose a name that used to
accurately represent you
as a different gender because this is
some new
incredibly important distinction that
we've decided
it takes precedence over everything else
including it's it's more significant
than
insults more significance than a
demeaning of i'd call you a [ __ ]
i could demean your intellect all those
things are fine but if i
choose to call you by a name that used
to actually
accurately represent you when you were a
different gender or when you
identified with a different gender
because of today's political climate
that is grounds for banning you for life
it shows you
how incredibly slippery censorship can
get
because i would have never imagined that
if you said to me 10 years ago
well when someone becomes a transgender
person 10 years
10 years ago if you said this to me if
someone becomes a transgender person you
call them by their original name you
could be banned from social media for
life i'm like get the [ __ ] out of here
they'll never get to that
no one's going to be that unreasonable
that's crazy because you could call some
people so many disparaging and insulting
names but you can't say
their name that isn't even insulting
dead naming that's what it's called so
it just shows you dead naming of today
you agree with that today that opens up
the door for all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
five years from now 10 years from now if
we still get more and more
rabidly politically polarized and
we are our idea of pc culture gets more
and more extreme
you're you're in you're on a greased
hill
and if you decide to give up a little
ground the slide is imminent
i i think this is like you can argue on
that axis
um but i think incrementalism and the
failures of imagination going you know
10 years ago we couldn't imagine this
would have been abandonable offense
is the wrong way to go about it because
if you go back to the founding of the
country
saying you know women should have the
right to vote black people should have
the right to vote you know that was
unimaginable that would get you
equivalently d platform not welcomed to
the the speaking
community or whatever sure but those are
positive and inclusive things right i'm
not saying
uh right i'm associating these directly
i'm talking about the principle here
uh because you can attack these things
in that direction go oh you know this
doesn't seem right but remember it's
twitter making these rules it's youtube
making visuals there's not a court
making these rules
um and anybody technically today can
decide who and can and can't
uh who can and cannot speak on their
platforms the question is
what should we do what kind of culture
should we promote
how should we have these conversations
and how should we make them available
and i think civility is not too much to
ask people generally as you say
you know calling people [ __ ] face or
[ __ ] or whatever is completely normal
um on the internet and that's not really
gonna get you banned from anywhere
uh and now you have all of these
companies sort of uh contorting
themselves to fit into these blocks to
not uh or
sort of anger all of these different
demographics
but if we truly want to have
a global broadcast a public commons the
question
i think that's more important here is
not so much
uh what should and should not be banned
because that's accepting the premise of
banning
it's how do we create an inclusive uh
platform where everyone can talk and
even strictly and harshly disagree with
each other
without it coming down to name calling
without trying to dox people without
trying to
uh basically dog whistle them or screw
them or hurt them or harm them
however now look i am not above calling
people bad names on the internet
i've said terrible things i grew up on
the internet right i was an
[ __ ] right and we all were and the
thing is
the worst things that we say at any
moment today
they are permanent the internet never
forgets right so
when you say these things and you know
there's a young audience
listening right now to to like
everything
um and they think it's cool they think
it's funny or they don't think it's
cooler they don't think it's funny
but they think they shouldn't be the
platform for it they they they're edgy
you know they push the lines or whatever
they get that out there and they start
emulating this behavior they start
saying mean things they start saying
cruel things i did it myself right
not in this context but in whatever the
equivalent would be you know
20 years ago um
and that's there are going to be
consequences for that they're going to
be judged by that
whether they should or should not
whether it is right or wrong because as
you said there's so much tribalism today
and i think we have to create positive
examples i think you're right
the deplatforming is a huge issue it is
a tremendous issue right
but we should think about what it is
that we're actually uh fighting against
and i don't think like trans issues or
whatever uh
when it comes down to basically civility
is the hill to die on because i think
there's better arguments
well i i certainly think we should
encourage civility
there's no no doubt about it what i'm
getting at
is that the idea that you can be banned
for life for that
is it's preposterous i think civility is
one of the most important things our
culture could ever promote
and i and i think it's very difficult to
promote civility online
because the anonymous aspect of there's
no accountability internet interaction
right there's no accountability there's
you're not getting social cues from
people
it's just a completely different world
when you're interacting with people
especially
for kids you know i mean if you had
given me the internet when i was 15
years old i would have said the most
horrific things to people
for sure and i'm sure many 15 year old
kids are doing exactly that right
now i think the more we can encourage
civility
the better we all are in all aspects of
our life whether it's
it person to person face to face or
online
i try very hard to only say things
that i would say to someone's face and
if you uh online now
i do not interact with people in any way
shape or form that's negative i don't do
it
i don't i don't believe in it i treat it
the same way
if it's avoidable i avoid it and i i
think that's incredibly important
but this does an important point which
is i mean
what it really gets to the core of the
issue failures of civility
the fact that people say bad things that
people don't have accountability that
there are you know there's a whole
spectrum of people out there
from angels to devils right there's
ordinary people and
even the best of people have bad days
and say terrible things
for sure we're all we do need people to
have some responsibility
for having a thicker skin you know hey
look guys
i've had people literally advocating my
murder right like that just torture and
murder literally
horrible things yeah yeah i've seen it
in years
um and the people that i've blocked on
my twitter account
are the ones who are posting about like
bitcoin scams that are like you know
send me five bitcoins
um i'm not saying this is the example to
emulate
uh what it is though is we have to
recognize
that some people aren't worth engaging
some people aren't worth listening to
um it's a lesson right but that doesn't
mean necessarily that you take their
voice entirely
yes i i i most certainly agree with that
in in terms particularly in terms of
de-platforming my question to you
about this is and i've raised this
question many people and i
really haven't got a satisfactory answer
do you
think that things that get so huge
like twitter uh or facebook or even
youtube
do they become a basic
right is it like the utilities
is it like electricity and water is like
the ability to communicate
online seems to me a core
aspect of what it means to be a human
being with a voice in 2020.
and i don't think it's as simple as
removing someone
from twitter is simply a company
uh exercising their right to have
whatever they want on their platform
i think when it gets as big as twitter
is i think we've
passed into a new realm and i think we
need to acknowledge that whether it's
twitter or youtube or facebook or what
have you
i mean and i think it should be very
difficult
to remove someone from those platforms
and i think it should
probably involve some sort of a trial i
mean this is much
uh this is a really really tough issue
it's much larger than just d
platforming because what we're really
talking about is the internet is a
public utility
right the internet is water and power um
and its ability to shape culture right
right
um when you talk about something like
you know twitter and the size
when the president is basically
directing uh policy
from twitter uh it's clear sometimes
threatening countries
that is our laws were not
designed with that in mind and
unfortunately we have a legislature
that's just fundamentally broken
uh this gets back to the the electoral
system which you talked about earlier
you know most countries in the world
have a wide swath of parties they're not
this two-party binary system where it's
just
two groups largely new corporatist
groups that are just handing power back
and forth the president changes
but the actual lawmakers the actual
structure behind the president the
advisors
are largely from the same cohorts
we we don't have that
legislative we don't have that
governmental structure
that allows us to adapt in a way that
truly represents i think the broadest
spectrum of public opinion
in a way uh that allows us to respond to
changes in technology in a meaningful
way which is what's left us stranded
today
where these companies are are sort of
deciding things for themselves it's
because there is a vacuum
uh of legislation
now there's a question do we want
legislation people on
different spectrums from authoritarian
to libertarian here will go we want lots
of legislation we want no legislation
um but there is a push and there has
been a push in congress for
years actually since the 90s uh with the
communications decency act and the first
crypto war
uh where the government was treating um
the ability to encrypt your
communications to to make them
secret uh or private as you communicate
with people online they were treating
that
as a weapon and saying you couldn't
export this code without getting a
license from the government and all
kinds of craziness
but the communications decency act the
idea that there would be obscenity
regulations the
some years ago you may remember a
scandal involving backpage which was
like a
variant of craigslist that had a lot of
prostitution ads on it
um government has been trying more and
more
uh to say these kind of things can be
done on the internet these kind of
things can be said on the internet these
kind of things can't be said on the
internet
and they have been doing this largely
under the guise i would argue
of the commerce clause right the federal
government where they get the
constitutional authority to regulate
what we say and do businesses wherever
well they go well the internet is global
it's international therefore it's
interstate commerce and so we're going
to regulate this
as if you're you know shipping bushels
of corn from iowa to florida
but it's it's a little bit different
than that and i think
uh what we need to recognize is that the
internet
is a utility and people
uh individuals uh and corporate entities
you should be criminally liable
for the things that they do online that
means if they have caused enough harm
that you're willing to put them in
prison they've stolen from someone they
have
destroyed some piece of infrastructure
they have caused harm to someone
uh you know somebody died or they
plotted a murder or whatever
you take them through the courts you try
them on this the jury considers what
they did they consider why they did they
considered the evidence
and then you you uh let the trial system
the traditional system that we've had
for
thousands of years uh worked this kind
of stuff out or at least hundreds of
years
um but when you get the government and
you get officials in
congress you get officials you know
whatever the local department
of this country or that country you know
russia's got a telecommunications
censorship bureau
china's got one france germany the
united states all of these guys
i have different regulatory authorities
whether it's the fcc in the united
states or ra's comrades or in russia
and you cannot substitute their judgment
for the judgment of a jury for the
judgment of the people and the public
broadly
and i think it's dangerous that we're
trying to
have the government pick winners and
losers when whether you win or lose
determines whether or not you can engage
with the world whether you can have a
public presence uh
on the internet because the internet is
real life
today yeah it is and
could it be that the option would be to
extend
the first amendment rights to the
internet in general
and to if you want to run a social media
platform
you know other than what we're talking
about putting people in danger doxxing
people threatening people's lives
doing things that can cause direct harm
to people but the ability to express
yourself in controversial ways
should shouldn't we extend first
amendment protections
to social media platforms i i think
this is a a much more complicated
question
than it appears because you get into the
whole thing of obligation of service
there is
uh like there was a cause celebrate on
the right
actually that would seem like a similar
issue
i remember there was the cake shop
somewhere where they didn't want to
serve
like a same-sex marriage thing uh and
again this gets back to civility
um but some people are they have a very
strong fundamental
uh belief here that these people
shouldn't be able to do this that or the
other
and if you impose that uh on them that
requirement on them they've got to serve
you know whatever their uh business is
to these people that they don't like or
that they don't agree with there's a
compulsion of service there
you start doing this with the internet
and then there's a completely different
com
country you know let's say there's a
website in belgium
that's now bound by american laws that's
bound by this
twitter can't ban this person even
though uh they're against them
it seems like isn't that a different
argument though because
all these companies were talking about
twitter facebook and youtube are all
based in america
now i agree imposing american first
amendment rights on the country
particularly if the u.s starts changing
laws but this is the interesting thing
about internet companies is they can
right
would that be their loophole yeah would
that be their loophole to get out of
that just selling
right but i mean it's it's more
fundamentally
um we have to recognize either as a
society we can compel
people to standards of civility
or we can't and we need to decide uh how
we handle that because that's what all
of these tie around
right um and i think we have
forgotten uh in many ways just
we're not teaching people the golden
rule well enough because we are all
angry
we are all in competition and the funny
thing is
uh the guy on the right who's poor and
living in a trailer
uh is not much different than you know
the hippie on the left who's
scrounging out of dumpsters you know uh
and and raising their black flag to go
to a protest
they act like they could not be more
different but their economic
circumstances could not be more similar
and the reality is
it's you know the the government uh the
the lawmakers and the business owners
that are setting them at odds and we are
all getting lost in our own ideological
differences
uh and losing sight of the things that
actually tie us together and that if we
worked together maybe we could change in
a more meaningful way
and the more people you meet the more
people you talk to you more you realize
how malleable people really are and
about how
so many of these ideological
perspectives that they they so
rabidly subscribe to they've adopted
because it
allows them to be accepted by their
community by whatever
neighborhood they're in or whatever
group of people they hang out with and
they choose to
adopt these uh these ideas about how the
world is and
so many of those people just don't
experience people that are
are different from them i mean that that
is the case with racism that's the case
with homophobia that's the case with
many
of the issues that people have with
other folks is that they just don't know
people from those other groups and they
haven't experienced you know
they haven't walked a mile in their
shoes as it were i
i think civility should be encouraged as
much as possible
also though i'm a comedian and i
i talk a lot of [ __ ] and that's in in
the sense of humor
like you can miss and it's been done
against me many times
where they've taken things i've said in
jest and put them in quotes
completely out of context and it looks
horrible
because that's not what it that's not
the way it was intended
and it was intended in humor now if you
do have
laws that not just encourage civility
but uh mandate civility you're gonna
have a real problem with humor
because you're basically gonna cut cut
the ankles out of comedy
um not that i'm saying that all humor
has to be mean and vicious it doesn't
but some of the best is well it's also
about saying things that can't be said
you know yes yes saying things that
can't be said
um i i think there's a there's a giant
problem
with uh online censorship today i i
i think it's one of the biggest problems
of our era and i do think it is because
there is a massive slippery slope um and
i do
uh agree with you about the cake people
you know that that was a
a big issue was that cause celebrate the
right of these people they should have
the right
a lot of people felt to not make a cake
for someone who is doing
who is doing something they think is
immoral right being
uh involved in a gay relationship but
there's also the problem
of sensationalizing these things because
the people that
did find those people that didn't want
to make those cakes
they went to a bunch of people that
agreed to make the cake first
they went and tried to find someone who
didn't want to make that cake
and then they turned it into a big story
now even though i
i just think i mean i think you should
make a cake for gay people because
there's nothing wrong with being gay
but i think the people that made that
decision to not make that
i feel bad for them i feel bad that
they're they're bigoted in that way and
that it's
such a foolish thing to care who
someone is in love with whether it's the
same sex or an opposite sex
but also i think it's weird that someone
wants to go around and try to find
someone who won't make a cake for them
who wants to go from cake place to cake
place to cake place
until i go aha i found a bigot like and
then make a big deal out of it like you
know you're you're searching for
victimhood
i mean there's an argument that that's
uh
i mean that that's one way to look at it
another way to look at it is that's
activism
uh they're searching for injustice
right yeah i agree yeah this is the
thing like
what is right and wrong this is this is
what people forget uh
is changing constantly when we're
talking about public opinion because
public opinion
is changing constantly and this is why
doing right by people it's so sad that
we've lost sight of this
uh basic impulse to do unto others as
you would have them do unto you
uh yes
because when you talk about the internet
when you talk about de-platforming when
you talk about humor
as you said you know people are going
back and they're looking at your jokes
they're putting them in quotes there's a
different context you're being attacked
by it
uh something you said uh looks bad
there's there's things that
uh you've said things that i've said
things that the person listening right
now have said
that they believed that they meant
that they said ten years ago that they
said one year ago that they said three
weeks ago
that they no longer believe that they've
abandoned that they've been persuaded
otherwise
they've changed their mind on and this
was one of the central themes in
in the book permanent record um
is we are no longer allowed
to forget our worst mistakes
right they're there they haunt us
they're used against us they're
weaponized
uh and this society has become aware of
this and activists on all sides have
become aware of this
uh immediately they use this to try to
attack people on the other side of any
issue
that they don't like to go after their
credibility to go after their character
and what we are losing in that
conflict and this is a rational strategy
on the part of both sides
in the moment because they realize there
is a real political advantage to be
gained you can get people cancelled
uh very easily nowadays but the the
thing is
when we make everyone
we pin everyone to their worst moment
when we do away with the concept of
forgiveness we we do away
with the potential for growth for change
for persuasion
and this gets back to those those rat
holes of
extremism on on uh youtube
on twitter on everywhere else where they
start
self reinforcing uh and eventually
reaching the bottom of the hole
at the worst of the worst with everybody
else who's been canceled too
and part of that is because they can't
climb out or they think they can't climb
out
and there's a question how do we resolve
that
one of the nice things about the the
pre-internet society
was as bad as you were as ignorant
as uh a racist as exploitative
as whatever you don't like right as that
person that character was
they could find something new they could
read a book they could meet someone they
could change their mind
and even if nobody in their town would
ever forgive them rightly
in some cases because they had done
something truly terrible something truly
unforgivable
they could leave they could move to a
different town they could move to a
different state and that history
would not follow them they could
reinvent themselves and they could
become
someone truly honestly better
instead of being married to their prior
ignorance
that is a very important thing because
we all
are in a constant state of growth if
you're not you you're really making some
fundamental
errors with your life we're all in this
constant state of
accepting and acquiring new information
gaining new perspectives learning from
our mistakes
and if unless you're dr manhattan unless
you're some person who's not making any
mistakes
and you just have this all-knowing
vision of the world you're a finished
product
like please if you are share that with
everybody else
but most of us are not most of us are in
this weird state of being a human being
on earth where everyone is trying to
figure it out in this incredibly
imperfect world
incredibly imperfect society the the
everything from
the structure the economic structure to
the societal stuff everything
down to the very last things
everything's imperfect and the idea
should be
that we're all communicating to try to
grow together
and that we're learning together and
it's one of the more interesting things
about interacting with people online is
that you can
get different perspectives and if you
can let go of your ego
and if you can let go of your
preconceived notions you can learn
things about the way other people see
and feel and think about
the world that could change and enhance
your own
ideas and i think that that's
it's important that we not just accept
the fact
that people are growing and getting
better and improving
but that we encourage it we encourage it
and we reward it
and i i think that's one of the
interesting things that
we're struggling with i mean you see
this in the context of police violence
you you see this uh
in the context of mass surveillance you
see this in the context of cancer
culture you see this everywhere
one of the interesting things about this
surveillance machine
that has been built around us the the
sort of architecture of oppression the
turnkey tyranny
as i describe it um so much is known
about every person
regardless of how innocent or how guilty
they are
it's all in there you know the files are
waiting to be accessed the the data
just needs to be collated it's it's just
waiting to be requested and analyzed and
used
what this means like there there's this
old idea of the panopticon
right um which is you you create
a prison that is circular and
in the middle of it there's this great
tower right that rises way up and at the
very top of the tower
there's a mirrored glass room that the
warden
sits in and no prisoner knows where the
warden is looking because the warden can
see out but they can't see in
and so everyone believes that they are
watched
and so the idea is that no one will
misbehave because they're all afraid
uh that they'll be retaliated against
for breaking the rules or whatever
but what we have seen as this
surveillance machine has been built
is we all realize uh
intuitively and intuitively innately
inherently in ourselves
even if we don't recognize it even we
don't speak to it we witness it in the
news every night
there are records of wrongdoing
criminality in government the highest
and lowest levels of our government
uh corporations and uh
you know prominent uh figures in society
breaking the rules
ordinary people jaywalking littering you
know uh
polluting small-scale petty stuff
all of that somewhere there is a record
of
but in almost all cases it's not
punished
what has happened is we have broken
the chain of accountability between
knowledge of wrongdoing uh
and consequence for wrongdoing and this
happened without a vote
it happened without our participation we
weren't asked uh whether this was okay
but i think in some way that is
beginning to change the moral character
of people and what we need to do
starting with the top rather than the
bottom because china's trying to do the
reverse they're going
all right well there's a simple solution
to this let's just start screwing
everybody who breaks the rules instantly
and immediately
you know you got a social credit score
you you
protested so you're going off to a camp
you know whatever
um but imagine uh what it would mean
if we saw people where
now any official the minute they are
guilty of the slightest infraction
that immediately is exposed in the press
they go on trial they go on all this
stuff they're ruined they're disgraced
um but it turns out every other member
of
congress is going to court in the same
week because everybody is in violation
of something somewhere
we all have some measure of guilt large
or small
even if we're completely innocent
because you know our legal code is so
complex there's no way you can make it
through a week without
breaking some kind of rule about you
can't wear a green hat on tuesday
but if this happened if there was
accountability for
fractions of the rules any time an
infraction of the rules was
witnessed the laws would change
instantly to enshrine the right to
privacy
because the people in power wouldn't
want to lose their position of power
they would not want to lose this
position and suddenly
when they have skin in the game they
would realize oh everybody
deserves this um and i i think there's
just something interesting to that i
haven't thought this out
all the way fully so this could be you
know i
give give me some slack here but i think
this is really what has changed
um we have built a panopticon
but what sits at the top of it is a
computer
uh that computer witnesses
everything we do in reality it's a
distribution of computers
they're owned by many people an answer
to many people
but it does not yet judge us for us
judge us for it and what is happening is
the audience society the people have
realized that they can
see through this computer they can see
through the panopticon from a certain
angle a certain degree in a certain
direction any given time
the cops that have been you know
monitoring all of us for
years right they've got surveillance and
drones and stuff that they couldn't
imagine they
imagined in generations prior but now
every person on the street
has a smartphone with a camera too and
the cops are being witnessed
for the first time and now people are
trying to impose upon them
the same judgment that has classically
been imposed upon
us and this i think is one of the
uh dynamics that the changes that is
leading to this increasing
conflict in society is when you realize
that the people that throughout you know
uh
your generation's youth
were told in hollywood and stories are
our common shared national myths
you know the government's the good guys
the fbi's are going to get the gangsters
and
terrorists and things like that they're
the best of the best the fact that they
are people too
they're not only fallible but in some
cases you know small-minded and vicious
they are political they are partisan
the same way everyone else is people
start
questioning power and how it is used the
basic legitimacy the way it impacts our
lives what the limits of it should be
but people yet have not realized
uh one of the responses to this should
be a limitation
on the amount of power the government
has or rather not just government
but institution institution is a concept
right government or corporation
um the powers of institutions should be
limited to interfere in our lives
instead what they are trying to do both
sides you know blue team red team
whatever
they're squabbling they're fighting over
who has
their hands on the trigger who gets to
aim the weapon
rather than should the weapon exist
are you talking about police violence
when you're when you're saying these
things
that's a part of it yes it's it's every
direction but police
violence is very much the public part of
it we see right now
yeah that seems to be one of the most
complex
uh abuses of power because
the the kind of power that you give
someone when you
allow them to be a police officer is
literally the power to end life
it's not just the power to kick you off
twitter it's the power to decide
this this person who's just a regular
person no different than you or i with
all sorts of problems in their own life
and
stresses and strains and a
disproportionate amount of strain
and stress for the actual job that they
do it means a spectacularly
stressful position to be in life but yet
you give them
the ability to literally with a finger
pull
end someone's life i think that's being
exposed
in a way that we've because of these
cell phone cameras and because of uh
social media it's being exposed in a way
that we no one ever would have ever
dreamed
uh imaginable before and exposing
how almost impossible it is
to have that position as a human being
and
i mean this the position of power
like that over folks and just to have a
regular person with a normal psychology
and
and not some incredibly brilliant zen
master who's
in charge of uh you know overseeing drug
crimes
or pulling people over or or you know
assault or whatever it is
it's it it i don't know the solution to
that
i you know there's all sorts of things
at play
ignorance foolishness racism anger
but at the end of the day it's about a
human being's
ability to have a massive amount of
power by law
over other human beings which is always
going to be a problem
it's just going to be a problem yeah i
mean i
i think we've known about this you know
there's aphorisms that go back a zillion
years you know
absolute power corrupts absolutely um
you know you give a monkey a stick the
first thing he's going to do is he's
going to look for something to hit with
it
but this is also one of the things you
asked earlier about like
how i can be hopeful how i can be
idealistic when i
see the scale of the problems the
challenges the rate against us
when i understand not just that mass
surveillance exists
but i understand the mechanics of it i
understand how systemic it is
i understand the resources behind it
that want to prevent the change of it
and instead want to entrench it and
expand it
to make it more powerful and have more
influence over the direction of our
lives
down to this basic stuff about you know
we are told
the cops are the best among us people
sign up to be cops i genuinely believe
because they want to serve and protect
more so than they just want to be the
big tough cop guy
and some people say you know that's
naive some people say that's petty but i
i think it's different i think the
reason that i feel this way
the reason that i am okay with seeing
how much we
fail uh seeing how much incivility and
violence and
and just ignorance that we have in the
world today is
is i have a lower expectation
of the individual at the moment
but a higher appreciation for their
potential
and the reality is we are all inherently
flawed
i'm a terrible person uh
and i i think in a lot of ways uh you
are not as good
as you want yourself to be but i know
that
i have become a better person with time
you have become a better person with
time i think we all
have and we all can or those of us who
have not
could if they chose to or if they had
guidance or if they had love or
friendship or someone
who cared and directed them and helped
them become better
uh yeah and that's i mean that is the
story
of human history because we were all the
monkey and then we found a stick
uh we could use it to beat somebody or
we could use it to build a bridge but if
you look around at the world today
there's a hell of a lot of bridges
there are in the i think in terms of
police brutality
there's very few reasonable
solutions that seem to be actionable
seem to be something that you could just
put into play
right away in terms of like how do
you how do you deal with these
violent encounters that police officers
often have with people
how do you deal with the ptsd that
i believe a vast majority of these
police officers suffer from
completely stressed out every time they
pull someone over it could be the end of
their life they
might not go home to their families they
really don't know and i think there's
also a bunch of them that
are emotionally and psychologically
unqualified for the job
to begin with and then here we are
uh with these calls in america at least
to defund the police
which i think is even more ridiculous i
think if anything they need more funding
and more training and a more stringent
uh process of elimination of
removing people that aren't qualified
for that job because i believe very few
people
actually are qualified i think there's
great police officers out there i really
do and i think
most of them most of the interactions
that people have with police officers
aren't horrible but there's enough of
those horrible ones that are captured on
video
that we have this bias towards these
negative results that we see over and
over again
and we don't take into account the full
data set we're not taking into account
all the interactions that people have
with police officers because those
aren't documented
what we're getting in front of our face
day in day out are the terrible
interactions and um i don't
see nor do i hear a real workable
way of improving this um you you get
people
that are either calling to defund the
police or you're calling for people to
support police officers that's all you
hear
i i from a few people like jocko willink
you see uh
really great suggestions that they
should be treated the same way they
treat navy seals
where you're spending literally 20 of
your time training
and you're going through psychological
training you're going
through uh actual real world uh
situations where you're you're going
over
what's the correct protocol and how to
handle certain situations
and i i think it's it's
a giant problem in our society today and
i think that's an understatement
that every time someone gets shot that
shouldn't have gotten shot
particularly if it's a person of color
it becomes a
a gigantic flash point uh for our
society
well let me challenge you on that a
little bit because i mean
we can we can have civil disagreements
in the way uh you know that's that's why
we have
discussion i think there are things that
we can do
uh that don't require you know the idea
of shutting down every
police department i i think that's sort
of
far beyond what people talk about when
we they talk about defunding the police
i think
the most common sense uh measure that
is being discussed and it's not being
discussed as uh broadly in terms of like
the mainstream news
it should be is ending police unions
right now why do we talk about that
um this gets back to the same thing that
we talked about earlier with the court
cases and the government you know they
get
caught doing something wrong but there's
no consequence
right and people learn from that each
generation learns from the cases prior
right it's in training and people learn
rules things like that
the reason a lot of police violence
occurs
um even if it's not all it's not again
there's there's no magic wand we wave
that saves the world
is the lack of accountability uh we know
there are cops
and even cops say this right uh there
are cops out there who
aren't good people uh there are cops out
there who have used their authority
uh there are you know really tragic
cases
uh where a cop has done something
straight up criminal
and they have faced no meaningful
consequences as a result maybe they lost
their job
right but if it was anybody else they
would have gone to prison
and so there's a question of how do we
remediate this
in a way that
preserves the legitimate interest of you
know police officers as a class
but it also preserves the rights of the
people who are being policed
in by your own admission at least some
cases
people who are abusing their authorities
and again i'm not saying all cops are
bad or anything like that
but if we recognize there are abuses
and this is a class that is invested as
you said with the power over life and
death
we have to be willing as a society and
the people occupying this position have
to be willing to assume
a higher standard of accountability than
ordinary people right
and if we can agree on that
everything else follows from it i think
we don't want to have
a gun-toting immunized class walking
among us
and i think even you know police
officers
among themselves at least would
recognize this
but it is rational for them to resist
this from the interests of their class
they're in a privileged position
why would they give that up the same way
our spies are in a privileged position
why would they give that up but as a
society
we exist to ask more and you raise valid
points right there's cops out there
go up to a dark car in the middle of the
night they're afraid they're not going
to make it home to their family
that's reasonable and legitimate right
but being a police officer
is a dangerous position that people have
signed up to we give our police officers
every advantage that could be given to
them today
i can tell you from having lived all
around the world uh
there's no cops in the world uh that are
kitted out like cops in america
are like the you know these these guys
look like
you know something from a sci-fi movie
um
and if there is a kind of well some of
them do some some of them
are going to riot and look there's good
cops out there
um i had a lot of interactions with cops
as a young man
uh that were nothing but positive uh
it's not that police as an idea are the
enemy
it is the system that is rotten and i
think even honest cops
recognize that the system is funnily
been mentally broken
the question is not or the question from
their side should not be
can we stop reform because if they are
if that's their position i think they're
doing the public a disservice
and i think to themselves they know
they're doing a disservice
it's how do we handle this appropriately
how do we handle this
in the right way and if there's cops out
there who legitimately have served you
know they've been out there for years
they've been exposing themselves to
danger to keep people safe at night
they've done a good job uh and they
don't want to walk the beat
anymore that should certainly be an
option that's available to them and from
my perspective as not a cop
uh but i think when you look at um
the the state of law enforcement in the
united states that very much
is an option you know do they want to
work on dispatch do they want to work on
investigation
they want to be cross-trained in
forensics there are ways
uh that we can end issues or at least
mitigate
some of the issues that we see with
policing today
uh without saying cops are the worst
people in the world and without saying
you know these guys
should be above the law well i don't
think anybody's saying they should be
above the law but but factually to you
so your feelings
are excuse me i said factually today
like as a matter of fact whether we like
to or not
you gotta admit in most cases cops are
bulletproof
well i don't know i don't think i agree
with that i mean if you you look at what
happened in the george floyd case
obviously
they were caught on camera so we're
we're fortunate we got to
not fortunate but we got to see what
happened
and they reacted accordingly you're
you're
what you were saying before you started
this though was that we need to stop
police unions right and that
but do you think police unions aren't
only
around to protect people from the
consequences of
uh terrible policing they're also to
provide health insurance and and
reasonable amounts this is a great
argument for everybody to have
health insurance oh for sure yeah no i
agree
i think health insurance is a i think
it's a fundamental right of being a
human being in a
in a civilized society i think it should
be treated the same way we treat the
fire department
i think it should be something that we
we all agree we should pay into because
it
benefits all of us i mean i just think
uh
if if we are a community and that's what
really a country is supposed to be we're
supposed to be a large community
wouldn't we want to protect the most
vulnerable members of that community
that if you have a small knit family and
something happens to someone in the
family
everybody chips in to help that person
you know the
that's what i think health insurance
should be i think it should be
an important part of a culture of a
community
of a group of human beings that decide
they're all on the same team
we have to take care of the most
vulnerable people i mean i think that
across the board and i mean
that's really the argument that i'm
making for how we want our police to be
when i say
you know cops are bulletproof i don't
mean in the literal sense there are a
lot of cops who have given their lives
uh to stop very bad people and we should
honor them we should provide for their
families
but the way that we do that is providing
a better society that's more fair to
police
by being more fair to everyone right
as long as as long as we've got any
occupation
that has it it's really this simple as
long as we have an occupation
that is invested with exceptional
authority
they must be investigated invested with
a
extraordinary standard of accountability
it's that simple from my perspective
like it doesn't have to be a terrible
thing it doesn't have to be aggressive
attack but it's this basic principle
today in the world of business in the
world of government
in the world of policing anywhere you
look right it's a common issue
what we have is a disproportionate
allocation of influence
a disproportionate allocation of
economic resources
disproportionate economic or a
disproportionate allocation
of authority without
an equal allocation of responsibility
well i i think we both agree on that and
i think we also both agree that it's not
a shock
that a disproportionate amount of
criminal activity exists in a place
where there's a
disproportional amount of poverty sure
and a disproportionate
yeah i mean this is an and very few
economic
opportunities i mean this is something
people don't that is a real problem
but you're exactly right i mean when you
talk about yes
uh where terrorist movements arise from
when you talk about where
criminal groups uh really thrive it's
where there is poverty
uh poverty breeds desperation
uh desperation breeds anger uh
and resent and and sadly due to the
nature of our species
uh that in many cases inevitably tends
toward violence
uh if we want to solve the uh
uh which are criminality right uh
because people forget terrorism is a
crime
it's very grave crime but it's still a
crime uh we have to go to the core
causes
yeah and you know we were talking about
this previously on a different show
in regards to the way people reacted to
the pandemic in terms of economic
support to businesses and
trillions of dollars that were allocated
to all these various businesses to try
to stimulate them and keep them active
and
and alive and keep people working and my
thought was like
imagine if that same attention to detail
had been to impoverished neighborhoods
if they had decided
like listen there's obviously a
disproportionate amount of crime and
poverty
in these neighborhoods we've got to
figure out a way
to lessen that burden and strengthen
those neighborhoods and
in a real simplistic way of putting it
the way i've always said
if you want to make america great you
want less losers
right what's the best way to have less
losers
have more people with an opportunity to
succeed
more people who grow up in an area where
it's
actually safe where there's economic
possibilities
where you're you're you're given more
access to education
more access to health care more access
to counseling
more access to uh community centers
any kind of support that you could
possibly give people that gives them
more of an opportunity to get by in life
and that this is something that we've
conveniently ignored this this this need
to strengthen
these core and significant areas of our
culture
but yet we do when something comes along
like a pandemic that might close down
business and already thriving economic
businesses
i think we should have put i think a
long time ago we should have put
similar resources and attention into
these
impoverished neighborhoods that have
been impoverished for decades
and a lot of it because of slavery and a
lot of it because of redlining laws and
jim crow laws and
all the things that happen after slavery
there's so many areas of our country
that just don't get better and we don't
do anything about it
and we just assume that these cr these
crime-ridden areas will remain that way
forever
and they send cops there and then the
you you see the videos of the
interactions the cops have with people
and it just creates more and more anger
and more and more frustration without
any real
uh so some sort of uh socially
responsible
action by by the government and some
some sort of a program where it's
explained to people
explain to the general public how this
is going to benefit everyone
that we will have less crime that we
will have more opportunity we
will have more people that are that are
educated and empowered
entering into the workforce will have
more competition they'll strengthen the
country as a whole
it'll be better literally for every one
of us
and that this is something that they
didn't pursue
and they haven't pursued in this country
forever
well i mean this is this gets back to
that the question that i was asking
earlier
it's one that i ask myself you know when
you look at all the problems of today
and you know for for somebody who's
focused on privacy and surveillance
issues
it's easy to be reminded every day of
how deep in the hall we are
where did these things really
you talked earlier about like a greased
hill where where did the
incline increase where did things start
to really go wrong
because they've always been going wrong
in in in some area
again that's our burden uh we've got to
make things better because they're never
going to be good enough
uh where we start but in
recent decades things have gone bad and
i think it goes back to patriot act
and you ask about economy you talk about
poverty you talk about
opportunity how do we fix this
everybody is rehabilitating him now as
this you know nice little
old guy painting his feet in the bathtub
uh
but the patriot act george bush in the
iraq war
um and the policy of endless war that is
continuing
sadly today it's a bipartisan thing
continued under obama
continued under trump um
we have spent trillions of dollars
trillions of dollars uh
killing far away people who literally
going by the statistics are more likely
to be non-combatants than combatants i
think
um collateral damage is a real thing and
even if
every one of those people was someone we
didn't like
uh was the level of effort was the level
of resources that we invested in it
uh was the cost to our national
soul worth whatever it is we can be said
to have gained
uh and i think the answer is that we
have been
uh generationally diminished
not by that president alone but by the
policies that that administration
uh popularized that had been embraced
and continued
uh by the administration since until we
learned that lesson
um we you me everyone else will have an
obligation
uh to try and change things to return us
to a better path
i i agree with you and i also think
there's a real good argument
that there's certain aspects of
technology that have been implemented
in in terms of like warfare and how we
deal with terrorism
that you could say short term perhaps
might have eliminated some targets but i
would argue long term
probably encouraged more people towards
radical fundamentalism
particularly drones when i tell people
the
efficacy of drone attacks and how many
people
who are killed by drone attacks what
i've gone into with people that really
haven't focused on it the amount of
people that are innocent that are killed
by drones
and the the vast majority of that being
the case
that when you're dealing with a hundred
drone deaths it might be like
84 of them are innocent like imagine
that being anything else imagine if the
police did that
if you know they prevented crime by
killing 84 percent
completely innocent people you would say
that's insane like we have to stop that
immediately but because it's done with a
robot that flies through the sky
remotely from nevada by some guy with an
xbox controller
and he's launching missiles into some
sort of a
a car convoy that
we've accepted this and i think there's
a real argument
that that is it's being accepted because
of the remote aspect of it
because we don't we don't see it we
don't feel it it seems
distant and even seems distant from the
person that's holding
the remote control they're saying that
the people that are doing that that are
responsible for operating these drones
are experiencing
a new level of ptsd and a very severe
form of it
many of them they're they're haunted by
the idea of what they've done and the
fact that
even though their own hands have done it
they weren't there to see it
it's some sort of a bizarre disconnect
and that they're murdering literally
who knows what percentage but it's a
very high percentage of innocent people
now this gets us back to uh what i was
talking about
in in calling for the pardon of these
different whistleblowers
um this is the core issue of daniel hale
daniel hale is an american who i believe
is still
on trial they have yet to be convicted
but the government is going to
bury this man if they get the chance for
revealing abuses
in the drone program and the failures of
the drone program
uh and this also gets you know you talk
about this question of efficacy and
percentages we we talk about mass
surveillance
uh just last week this was covered
nowhere
in media that i've seen so far in a
prominent way i think the washington
post
uh wrote an article but it you know it
was buried it wasn't like a front page
a1 sort of top of the
fold splash on the fisa court a lot of
people have heard about the fisa court
because the relationship to the trump
thing
um i hope one of your guys who works in
production can pull out
uh you know a headliner front page or
the the the twitter thread
from elizabeth coyteen i think it's at
liza goyten who went through this
it was published and declassified
version of the fisa
uh reauthorization for last year
where the court goes through every year
and the fbi submits this request
for basically a blanket surveillance
warrant that they can use
on all these different people for all
these different um
sort of categories of behavior that they
want to monitor
and the fisa court reauthorizes this
annually um
and in this uh annual review they look
at
is the system functioning is it
effective were the rules broken
uh and uh one of these experts i think
she worked at the brenner
brennan center for justice um
correct me and edit me out if i'm wrong
here but
um there were thousands of cases in the
last year
thousands of cases where the fbi looked
people up
under uh the aegis of a fisa warrant
right and this is like a mass warrant
that's used for multiple people instead
of one for everyone else and we know how
bad
these fisa warrants can be and over the
course of
thousands of cases
the court found that they had been
unjustified
in uh looking up these people's
background in all but
seven cases i think it was seven cases
out of thousands
and this is uh where it's at we have
created a procedural state a
bureaucratic state
an uh automated system
for policing and i mean that broadly
don't just mean you know guys in
in in in shiny shoes on the ground with
a pistol on their waist
uh i'm talking about is it platform
behavior and speech
on twitter i'm talking about is it
surveillance behavior both domestically
against american citizens and abroad
around the world
we are trying to create a system
that observes everyone and judges
everyone in a way that we already know
is not fair it is not used properly it
is not used appropriately it is not used
effectively
and i believe uh does more harm than
good
and why are we trying to create a system
that sees everything we do and judges us
which is effectively trying to invent
god uh
when we know that it is a dark and
vengeful one
we need to think about the kind of
technologies that we are putting in
place
that rule us but we do not effectively
control
well i think there has to be
repercussions
when you're talking about that where all
case seven of them
the court said oh yes the fbi broke the
rules routinely they did it all the time
uh so we're gonna go ahead and
reauthorize this for next year here's
your rubber stamp come back in you know
12 months exactly but what i'm saying is
i think we as a society
need to demand repercussions for these
overreaches
because it's it's it is a violation of
law
and if it's a violation of law with no
consequences then it's not
then they're we're not talking about law
anymore we're talking about nonsense
we're talking about things you could
just get away with it really is it's a
king class it's someone could just get
away with things
what's the law it doesn't make any sense
or a law that's only enforced against
the powerless but not against the
powerful
right particularly if you or me or jamie
had done the same thing we would for
sure be in jail for a violation of
privacy for invading someone's privacy
for for doing something that is against
the law
if we were tried we would be convicted
we would wind up doing time
or pay some extraordinary fine we would
be in real trouble
is my point but they're not in any
trouble at all that you cannot have that
we can't have that in a society because
if you have that
ability to completely bypass
and any liability and any responsibility
for a violation of law then we've
created two classes of human beings
we've created uh human beings that are
the governed
and then we've created human beings that
are the governors and the governors are
exempt
and that's not that's not government
anymore now you're into some you're in a
monarchy
you're in some craziness yeah you're yes
you're rulers
and the ruled and you can't have that we
can't have that because
of what you said earlier absolute power
corrupts absolutely that is absolute
power
there's no repercussions whatsoever for
violating laws that can greatly
impact people's lives in a negative way
that's crazy
you can't have that we can't have that
and we need to agree
as human beings particularly now because
of the age that we live in and the
access to information that we enjoy
we're aware of this acutely it's obvious
it's it's right in front of our faces
and it's one of the many reasons why i
think you should be exonerated
well i think you should be pardoned i
mean you you've exposed this and you've
opened people's eyes to this
the the exponential increase in people's
understanding and appreciation
for that based on your
work and what the guardian put out and
and and
how you exposed all that it's changed
the conversation
it's changing and it needs to be changed
and the repercussions needs to be
changed as well
well thank you you know i i guess
there's not much more
uh to say than that but i hope uh
one day i will be able to come back um
if i want to see you in real life man
i'll come on the show
and be in the same room for once yeah
well hopefully covert will be gone then
well i'll test you first we'll test each
other first yeah yeah um
but listen i said it before i really do
believe this i think i think you're a
hero and i think that what you've done
history will be kind to you you know um
they will look
back on what what has been done to you
and i i think our government is on the
wrong side of history i really do
believe that
and uh i i think if people really did
know
know the facts and particularly the way
you
uh explained it earlier about how the
information was distributed
and and the way it was handled ethically
and morally
you did the best you possibly could have
done with that situation and i think
it's a
it's an incredibly bold move that you've
done and
and i i feel like uh the time has come
i really do and i i hope i hope
i hope trump listens to this i really do
i hope he listens to this and i hope he
he understands also what a a political
piece
it would be i mean this is a a massive
if he pardoned you i think you would be
a a a massively positive move for
his own the way the you know the united
states citizens
view him well i hope
what we see uh under this administration
or any other
but certainly we don't have to wait much
longer for is ending the war on
whistleblowers
because as much as i would like to come
home as much as i would like to see
recognition
uh from the system uh that there are
times when the only thing you can do
is tell the truth and that should not be
a crime
it's not about me it's about what
happens to all of us it's what happens
to the system and it's how we
restore
or rather realize the ideal of a country
that we were always told we had
uh but in reality we have never been as
good as what we dreamed
but we're getting closer and the way we
do that is by admitting where we were
wrong
and doing better thanks so much for
having me on again i
i really appreciate thanks for being on
man those words and that mentality
are what make you a hero and your
actions so i appreciate you very much
man
thanks so much stay free brother you too
my friend take care
[Music]